[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
SPEAKER 1: So, while
everyone is coming back,
I'll introduce Alexandra.
Alexandra
Deschamps-Sonsino, she is
an expert in internet of things,
a designer, and an innovator.
Some of her work has been
exhibited at the MoMA,
at the Victoria and
Albert Museum in London,
and the Design Museum in London.
And we look forward
to hear from her
around the internet of things.
[APPLAUSE]
ALEXANDRA DESCHAMPS-SONSINO:
I like how this is written
according to how
my passport is--
kind of the name on my passport.
They fucked up
and there's a dash
between the two, which now I
have to get used to not using,
it's very strange.
Awesome.
So I've posted these slides
online in case some of you
would like to express read
them and not listen to me,
which does happen sometimes.
Thank you for inviting me.
This is quite an unusual
event for me to attend.
I can't remember the last time
I said interaction design, HCI,
in a willing manner.
I tend to speak at quite
a lot of tech conferences,
people who do tech in a very
specific way, which is usually
the internet of things.
You'll find that I am this
kind of odd mixture, perhaps,
of someone who has a deep
history with some people
in the room who it's a
great pleasure to see,
because we don't see
each other very often.
It's even a bigger pleasure to
be speaking before one of them.
But also, I have progressed in a
really interesting manner where
now I spend a lot of
my time just writing.
I don't do a lot of design work.
I studied industrial
design, which I think
is a field that
will eventually die.
Yeah, go good.
And I also am finding
myself turning to old tools
more and more and old ways of
thinking more and more, which
is I'm probably the only person
who dragged along two books--
which I will be
referencing in my talk,
but I also have in real life--
should you want to look
at them before committing
to an online purchase.
It's like a lending
library on the go.
So I studied industrial
design, interaction design.
I was the first UK
distributor of the Arduino.
Who here knows what
the Arduino is?
That's not bad at all.
If you do not, it
is a credit card
sized open hardware education
platform for electronics.
If you've heard of
the Raspberry Pi,
it was a thing that was
there before the Raspberry
Pi was there and helped along
that whole ecology of products.
And I'm sure that Haiyan's work
will illustrate that further.
I have no examples of
the Arduino in this talk.
I do a lot of work
with a variety
of clients, usually
telling them what
I think about the internet of
things within their sector.
I'm also the founder of
something called the Good Night
Lamp, which I'm also
not going to talk about.
But it is a family of lamps
for global friends and family
that uses GSM, which
I don't recommend--
not the Good Night Lamp,
but just as a technology
stack to play with.
And for the last
seven years, I've
been the organizer of the London
internet of things Meetup.
You do have a meetup
here, which is where
I was speaking last night.
So and I do encourage
you to go to the Zurich
internet of things Meetup that
is run by my friend Thomas.
It's excellent.
And they're nice people.
They need a bit more
attendance from nice people
like yourself to have good
conversations about what
it means in Switzerland
to be an IoT.
I'm going to start with
something I never do,
which is sort of
quotes from people,
from famous people who usually
end up being white men.
But I find these
useful, because they
relate to the things I'm going
to talk about, one of which
is "Evolution is
apparently intent
that man fulfil a much
greater destiny than that
of being a simple muscle
and reflex machine."
And I think that
presentations that we've
heard this morning
and the conversations
that you must have
as an organization
relate to this
tension where we know
that the computer is there to
help us become something more.
It's just that so
much of our society
is actually built on the
idea of us being less
and being a reflex
muscle, machine.
The other one is--
and they're from
the same person,
weirdly, in the same book.
So it's quite handy.
And I have that book here--
is the "Behavior of
whole systems unpredicted
by the separately
observed behaviors of any
of the system's separate
parts or any subassembly
of the system's parts."
This is the definition
of Buckminster Fuller
for the word synergy, which we
don't use on purpose at all.
We kind of use in
quotation marks.
It's like the word
that everybody
hates using but
sometimes accidentally
uses to mean something
completely different.
And I find that
fascinating, because I
think that a lot of
the conversations that
are happening in the world,
that Sarah's work encapsulates,
some of the people who are here
from doteveryone encapsulates,
and some of my work
these days encapsulates
is this misunderstanding
of the parts
and misunderstanding of
the influence on the whole.
So maybe we should take
synergy and revisit it
with Buckminster Fuller's
sort of approach.
And I think, these
days, I kind of
feel like we're prepared
for the apocalypse
that we sort of planned for.
We have this imagery,
for the last 100 years--
and I'm writing a book
about smart homes.
So let me tell you I'm basking
in images of the future that
are very much about
things being connected,
this kind of hyperconnectivity
and, ultimately, a future
that is mathematically
coherent somehow.
There's always a circle.
There's always a
circle around things.
There's always circles
within circles.
There's lines of things.
Everything kind
of mathematically
somehow makes sense.
And visually, we feel like,
yeah, yeah, this is totally it.
This is totally
the future we want.
And I find that that's,
of course, a problem
because I don't
think that it allows
us to account for the times
when it's not like that, which
is almost always.
But we feel like we want
this future somehow,
because, you know, a
circle is a great shape.
It's a great shape
to believe in.
Triangles are also great shapes.
You use them a lot.
I don't have a triangle
in this presentation.
But I find it more interesting
to think about futures
that are completely incoherent.
And this is only a
very recent position.
This is not the kind of stuff
that I have done my whole life.
This is just a compound
of events and projects
that I have spent more
and more of my time
on that I'd like
to share with you.
Predominantly, something
called the Open IoT Mark.
I'll talk about what it is,
but it is a baby project.
It's sort of at its infancy.
It's less than a year old.
And it is an attempt
by a community
of people that are
less than 100 to look
at what it might mean to create
a certification mark for IoT.
So think of Fair Trade and
the Fair Trade sticker.
77% of British people know what
a Fair Trade sticker means.
It's a very clear, very
well-publicized sticker.
Think of what that
might mean in the world
of connected products.
What does trust
mean, ethics mean?
How do we do something
that is a Fair Trade
sticker for the world
of connected products?
That's what we're exploring.
That's what I'm spending
more and more of my time on.
And in the things that we're
exploring-- and this is a very,
again, small group of
people, mostly technologists,
would really appreciate
anyone in this room,
and in the extended
Google family
to have a look at what we're
doing-- but we're exploring
ideas of trusts and risk.
This is the more recent--
I suppose it's not technically
the more recent of my examples,
but it's the more recent
in a tangible way, which
is the VW emissions scandal.
A corporation, which
I shall not name,
which is German,
and a foundation,
provided the censors to VW to
actually measure the emissions.
And in the world of
engineering, doing that,
you have to do it in
a very particular way.
And so someone, somewhere
sent an email to VW
to say, yeah, by the
way, just keep in mind
that this could be abused.
We're selling you this sensor.
It's going to go
in all your cars.
And you do what you want to
do with it, but just be aware.
And by doing that, have
absolved themselves
of any responsibility publicly.
They are not the
corporation which
is the one that
makes the headlines.
Because from an
engineering perspective,
they did the right thing.
And they did the
commendable thing,
and the protectable thing
in the eyes of the law
by sending that one email
from that one engineer, which
is really interesting.
Because that's what
trust means and risks
means within that area.
Who knows where this is?
Brownie points if you do.
You can yell it out.
Christchurch in New Zealand,
some years ago, obviously.
And I always think of trust
and risk in an engineering
space as this
space where we also
are quite happy to bumble along
with crappy decision making
and crappy structures of
living until something happens
that makes us go, mm, I
guess that we'll build things
in an earthquake safe manner
now, because the cost of change
is high.
The cost of taking
every single building
in New Zealand in both
islands and saying we're
going to tear everything
down and we're
going to rebuild it all to
code so that it's earthquake
safe is not feasible.
So we tend to wait till
bad things happen in order
to operate any change.
And this is because
we're people.
We're human.
We assign a particular cost
to immediate decision making
and we forget about the cost
of later decision making.
We're very myopic that way.
This is slightly more recent.
Brownie points for who
knows where this is.
Yes.
So, Florida.
Equally, here, the same
kind of conversation
around risk and trust.
Which is the engineer
called two days
before to say, hey, by the
way, we've seen some cracks.
You might want to look at this.
This might need to be patched.
And now this engineer is--
his entire career is being
sort of dragged in the dirt
because it turns out he was
involved in other projects.
And oh, my god, what does this
mean for the other projects?
As if that one
engineer was the one
responsible for an
entire project like this.
That no one else in the delivery
process, the people selling
the concrete, the people
okaying the launch,
whatever it might
be, no one else
has any responsibility
but this one person.
So we think about that in
terms of big structures.
We're kind of happy
thinking about those things
in terms of the structures
that surround us.
But we're sort of less
comfortable with it,
or it's newer to think
about it, in the things that
start to disappear around
us, the small devices,
the small consumer
facing devices.
We don't yet have a
really good structure
for what we should
expect, what risks looks
like, what trust looks like.
Or something as mundane and
as problematic as lifecycle.
We live in a world where
things will not last very long.
I am dragging my MacBook Pro
until it really literally dies
on me, even though I'm--
now, the nice people
next to me were probably
thinking who is this
person, because I'm
dragging an external keyboard,
because the keyboard died.
And I'm like I am
not giving up on you,
if you don't give up on me.
Because I refused to
give said corporation
that starts with an A
a large amount of money
yet again every other year.
And this one, this
baby, is like--
I bought it in 2013.
So I feel like I think we can
do another six months together,
I swear.
But lifecycle is a problem.
It's a problem in
everyday devices.
It's a problem in cheaper,
not even connected devices.
But it's even more of a problem
in the internet of things.
And because lifecycle has
become a problematic concept--
so we have something like this,
which I own at home because,
I, yes, drag books along
and external keyboards,
but I also do try to buy
the latest and greatest.
And this is an HP
smart ink printer.
It is basically a printer
that I used to own
and now I rent, because I
changed the process by which
ink is delivered to me.
Which means that
now this printer--
if my credit card or debit
card details change--
stops printing,
because it does not
recognize that the online
account is linked up
to it anymore.
And it gives me this really
weird message, like the printer
can no longer function.
It doesn't say why.
It doesn't go, hey, maybe
you replaced your debit card
and the billing kind
of process has changed.
I can now no longer
interact with it
until I change my
details online.
Like that's a whole new
interaction with something
that basically makes me want
to throw it in the garbage
immediately.
And it's already
a printer, which
is already the most
frustrating thing ever.
Who here names their
printers after their pets?
OK.
Right.
Two people.
I think we've got something.
I think we can start something.
And the lifecycle of this is
really strange, because now--
oh, five minutes,
wow-- these objects
have started having a
life of their own somehow.
So it's not even the
lifecycle of how I use it,
it's how it decides to be used.
We have, of course, more
problematic lifecycle issues
that relate to--
in the world of
IoT, companies that
come and go far more
rapidly than most.
And I'm kind of being
cheeky by picking Revolv--
because, obviously,
I'm not an idiot.
I know where I am.
But there are multiple
others in my community
that have come and gone in
the last two years or so.
And when a consumer buys
something from someone,
they don't necessarily think
at the back of their mind,
I hope this company
is successful.
I hope this company is
successful in two years.
I hope that this
thing keeps working
after this company dies.
Nobody wants to think
that way, because it's
sort of constantly thinking in
an early adopter kind of way.
Not everybody has
that kind of money
to throw constantly
at something.
Within this group of
people in the IoT Mark,
we talk about openness and what
open source can mean or not
mean.
And how could it be
used or not used?
And who on earth wants
to open source everything
and still be
commercially successful?
These are all really
difficult questions.
But openness might
mean that things
start to be useful both
for us as households,
and for the city,
and for researchers
in much of a broad way.
For example, if you
were using open data
for a particular
consumer product--
this is a crappy image, because
they still haven't got a better
image on the website.
But this is the air
quality egg, which
is an air quality monitor
that you buy for your home.
And it gives you your
air quality in your home.
And you can see the map of all
the other air quality eggs.
You sort of want that to be
connected to City University's
projects, or UCL's projects,
so that UCL and City
don't have to rebuild
another air quality monitor
to do some air
quality monitoring
and have to
commercially work out
their own kind of
manufacturing hellhole.
And you just want to
piggyback on what's
there in people's homes.
This is a company
called Nkube which
is in the UK which
makes a smart hub.
But it's a local smart
hub for your products.
And it's made in
an open source way.
But it's also made in a
way that is super secure.
So openness does not
preclude security.
Obviously, things
like Fairphone,
which have to do with
openness and transparency.
And they are two different
sections in our document.
Don't worry.
Permissions and ownership
being another one.
I did not want to put Nest here,
again, for obvious reasons.
I know where I am.
But I bought a Hive at home.
I installed a Hive at home.
I am not one of the lucky
people who actually owns
their own properties in the UK.
I rent.
So I moved.
And when I moved, I
called British Gas.
I said, can I have my Hive
with me in the next apartment?
No, you can't.
So I had to buy another one.
I got 50 pounds discount
on the next one.
But my online account is
still tied to the thing
that's in the other apartment.
And so I had to
create another account
with another email
address to get the app
to create a whole new profile.
And the poor bastards
in the old flat
are stuck with the thing
whose entire functionality--
and the kind of plus of Hive is
the fact that I can switch it
off with my phone online 20
minutes before I get home.
And so I now hold ransom
their device somehow.
Not, you know, literally.
I haven't sent them anything.
This is a friend of ours-- and
some of us in the room will
know who that is--
my friend Russell's wife, Anne.
They used a Withings device.
And that gives you a kind
of great way of interacting
with your weight.
And you can chart kind
of how you're doing
and with your exercise,
et cetera, except when
your weight and your
husband's weight
start to get a little too close.
And the device says,
hi, Russell, when
it's actually her and not him.
Time is up, wow.
Right.
So, all these are
considerations.
And I will skip through
these in like 5 seconds.
Here's some security
stuff in the 33 principles
that we have published.
We have eight categories
which we are using.
We are also working in a
completely open process.
So we do have GitHub things.
And we have open tools, which
we have literally just produced
in the last 24 hours, because
I gave a talk last night
at the meetup.
And I would, again,
love, love, love
to get your feedback
on all of this.
We're not the only people
doing stuff around this space.
These are 45 of the
other things that
are happening around the world
that touch this space that
are concerned with this space.
They are policy papers.
They're policy efforts.
They are white papers.
I mean we're part of a
global movement right now.
But I think that we need
more responsibility.
Top props for who
knows what this is?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ALEXANDRA DESCHAMPS-SONSINO:
Yeah, yeah.
So the iron ring, in which--
if you're Canadian like myself,
my brother is an engineer
and has this ring.
It is a physical reminder
of your ethical requirements
as a professional.
And we have also lots
of other frameworks that
have been created
by people long,
long ago dead who are awesome.
Marshall McLuhan's "Global
Village," which I have as one
of my lending books today,
which I really recommend.
The other one, which
is Neil Postman's
"Seven Questions
for Technology,"
which I also recommend,
they are like decades old.
And they're still
really useful frameworks
for asking ourselves questions.
And asking ourselves
questions really
about what the role
of computing is.
Really, really top marks
for who knows who said this.
And that is my last slide.
You'll be happy to
know [INAUDIBLE]..
"What the coming of
the computer did,
'just in time,' was to make it
unnecessary to create social
inventions to change
the system in any way.
So in that sense, the computer
has acted fundamentally
as a conservative force."
Is the creator of
artificial intelligence
himself saying this?
I leave you with this.
I thank you for your
time, and your attention,
and hope that we can have
some conversations after.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: We have a
little time for questions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey, there.
SPEAKER 2: Anybody?
I have one.
Oh, no?
OK.
Aha.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
perusing the principles
and they look really good.
I guess what's the
go-to market strategy,
I mean, in terms of getting
these actually to be used?
Do you think it works
better to sort of legislate?
Does it work better
through market pressures?
Do you think you
the Fair Trade label
strategy is going to work?
But Fair Trade's
premium, you know?
That doesn't apply
across the board.
So in a sense, I would want
some of those principles
to be used by everyone, not just
by the small sort of Fair Trade
subset.
ALEXANDRA
DESCHAMPS-SONSINO: Sure.
And-- the question
was about whether this
is a premium thing.
The certification
mark kind of model
is the one that we have
come to a conclusion about,
after lots of chats
with lots of lawyers.
They're always an
interesting group
of people to talk to
about implementability,
but also appetite for
trusted implementation.
So you can tell people
what they should be doing.
And they can tell
you, yes, that they
do do in a self-certified
kind of way.
There is nothing to
prove that they do.
And that's a problem for us.
Those other models which we
were exploring, one of which
is closer to something like
the Energy Star rating,
which is where you are
basically enabling anyone,
no matter how bad they
are, to be clear about what
it is that they are doing.
The little that they might
be doing, you're championing.
So we're definitely
in conversations
around which implementation of
this mark might be the best.
Again, if you have
thoughts and opinions,
we have a very active Slack
channel, and the usual means.
We have open calls every month.
We have newsletters.
We have face-to-face meetings.
So we'd love your feedback.
SPEAKER 1: There are
no-- you had a question--
SPEAKER 2: I'll surrender
my question to the floor.
AUDIENCE: So I just wanted
clarification about the sensor
in the VW diesel problem.
You seem to be implying that
the sensor suppliers had
some responsibility
in the scandal.
But was that really
what you meant?
And if that's true, how about
all the other suppliers?
ALEXANDRA
DESCHAMPS-SONSINO: Oh, sure.
But I mean the sensor
is the one that
actually is the most active
in enabling a rating.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't
the software be that?
ALEXANDRA
DESCHAMPS-SONSINO: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Can the
software be that?
ALEXANDRA
DESCHAMPS-SONSINO: Yeah.
But without the--
it's a little bit--
so the funny thing
about software
only is that ultimately
there is a thing that
needs to measure something.
So the buck stops with hardware
in some IoT applications.
Without power to a sensor,
you can't measure anything.
Therefore, you got no
data and no one owns it.
So there is a responsibility
that they share.
Their way of turning away
from that responsibility
is this email that
the engineer sent out
to say, oh, by the way,
we're doing the hardware bit.
You guys were going--
AUDIENCE: My real
question is, how do you
come to that sort of
causal blame analysis?
Because gun manufacturers
get their materials
from steel makers.
Do they also adhere to this sort
of causal blame responsibility
here?
ALEXANDRA
DESCHAMPS-SONSINO: There
are liability issues
across supply chains
and across manufacturers
everywhere.
And you trust your suppliers
to tick certain boxes,
whether that's standards boxes.
So I'm not going to be supplied
with the quality of plastic
that might include some lead
if I make my toy out of it.
There is trust and
legal frameworks
built into every supply chain.
We don't quite have
that connection
between this hardware
and software space.
And so a lot of the
projects that I showed--
the 45 different projects
that are around the world--
a lot of them now are
concentrating on security,
because they feel like
that's an easier box
to tick than to look more
transversely at ownership,
permissions,
openness, et cetera.
Because it is about
that complex connection
and back to that quote from
Buckminster Fuller, which
is the movement of each element
has unintended consequences
at a larger scale.
So that's kind of
why we're choosing
to pick minimum viable
everything on lots
of different levels,
because I don't think
it's future proof to
think in this siloed way
that, well, you know, my
responsibility lies here.
No, you're still making
a car that pollutes.
SPEAKER 2: All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: The next speaker--
I'm sure I'm not pronouncing
name correctly, Haiyan.